c'est sa musique numérique un peu
spécial sébastien castellion va revenir
sur ce passé parce que vous vouliez dire
voulaient vider votre sac depuis
quelques jours ça m'a alors il ya quinze
jours le 50 minutes inside racontez nous
tout les gens voyagent et on va pas
revenir sur les tristes et sans
traitement voilà moi je me suis je sais
ça m'a gêné j'ai été choqué non mais
reprenait tout plages étaient choqués
ils ont été emmenés mission plusieurs
jours avant la mort de johnny en faisant
un plateau à temps je parle du plateau
je parle pas des magnétos qui sont faits
en avant ce qui est tout à fait normal
dans toutes les rédactions un plateau en
jouant à la mort de johnny les belles
émotions moi ça m'a vraiment choquée je
n'ai rien contre
nikos kita n'est que des amateurs on l'a
déjà dit c'est un mec formidable mais
dans ce cas précis je comprends pas et
je ne comprends toujours pas pourquoi on
a laissé faire ça dans ce cas précis
johnny c'était un événement national
tout le monde sait tout le monde et a
fait le travail les gens sont partis de
bosser 80 matin il y avait aucune raison
de faire ça je ne pensais honnêtement au
camp maintenant je comprends pas moi ce
qui me gêne un peu c'est que j'ai eu un
soutien de énorme dans ce sur les
réseaux wi partiel dans dans le métier
est et ce qui m'a gêné le plus ce sont
des amis à moi dont les intérêts croise
ce nikos qui m'ont rayé de leurs deux de
leurs calepins donc moi pour cette
raison là je suis quelqu'un qui a
toujours dit ce qu'ils pensaient je
parle pas avec eux je pars avec mon
coeur donc je préfère toujours être de
ceux qui qui lève le doigt et qui parle
qui dénoncent ce qu'ils s'expriment que
d'être de ceux de ceux qui sont du côté
de ceux qui ont un intérêt parce que moi
même ma grand mère disait dans la vie il
ya de l'argent qui est plus cher et trop
cher gagner et moi ce temps là j'en veux
pas voilà c'est tout
je suis venu laver très bon ami à vous
qui vous parle même plus à cause de
cette histoire c'est que jamais revu non
mais c'est vrai demetri noh mais c'était
j'ai reçu un texto m'expliquant que
c'était il pouvait pas tolérer un
déferlement de haine de violence mais à
quelle heure potter est avec toi abou
fonds non mais faut pas exagérer on vous
a dit vous allez être grillé dans le
métier ou de ça c'est pas nouveau
vous allez être grillé à tf1 non mais
franchement je peux maintenant dire mais
peut-être in paris nommé peut-être fait
dans dance mesdames et vous faisiez quoi
sur tf1 de façon mal à l'ol actuellement
pas grand chose mais non mais peu
importe j'ai honnêtement ce qu'on a dit
ici c'était pas que ce n'était pas une
attaque c'était un sentiment profond de
gênes voilà si aujourd'hui on veut pas
dire d'avec parler que son coeur et dire
qu'on n'est pas content non pas ponton
on ne m'a pas choqué ça m'a gêné si je
peux pas dire ça ici faut que je fous le
change et des démissions franchement
vous ne saviez pas donc à cause de ça je
maintenant non seulement je dirai ce que
je pense mais cette fois-ci j'enlèverai
le filtre et là croyez moi ça va chier
est-ce que ce qui n'aidera monde un peu
voilà d'hypocrites nous on fait partie
date et moi ya des gens très bien en
télé comme partout il ya des gens très
bien qu'il ya des gens voilà va bien
comme partout aussi géraldine bah moi je
suis un mille pour cent d'accord avec
benjamin castaldi et pourtant j'étais
pas d'accord avec ce qu avait tout avait
dit par rapport à par rapport à nikos et
pour autant c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui à
une telle dictature des réseaux sociaux
on a toujours peur des signalements du
csa doc ya une sorte de langue de bois
on sait police et on de bien pensants
insupportable de robinet d'eau tiède et
je trouve qu'ici on est en direct
moi je suis globalement jamais d'accord
avec vous cyril voix s'est jamais
enflammé saab ses avocats me serviront
fin d'année et adorent ça et achêne
souvenir celui surtout vous dites ce que
vous pensez vous
et on a besoin de ça aujourd'hui on est
des téléspectateurs il faut il faut
qu'on devienne des bons citoyens qui en
comprennent ce qui se passe c'est vrai
que géraldine et moi je vous jure on
n'est jamais d'accord sur rien ben oui
c'est pour ça qu'on s'aime et c'est très
bien comme ça je vous en remercie merci
madame je trouve que la télé peut plus
hypocrite que la société tout court
il faut bien être même les animateurs
qu'on devrait le plus longtemps c'est ce
qui sans être la chance ou être prudent
à bâle aurait moi j'ai pas duré
longtemps mais non mais alors apprécier
il ya des grandes gueules qui sont à
part qui sont à part donc vous vous êtes
un ami m moi je suis pas d'accord sur ce
que tu dis sur nico surtout vu que
c'était inutilement violence sur nikos
mais effectivement il faut
maintenant une vraie forte personnalité
faut l'exprimer ça c'est sûr mathieu
alors très court sur ce qu'il dit sandy
coach tout à fait d'accord après le seul
bémol et je reconnais que j'en ai
souffert un tout petit peu quand j'étais
pas dans l'émission ou d'autres le seul
bémol c'est que nous on a effectivement
on a on a une tribune tous les soirs
devant un million de personnes pour dire
ce qu'on veut pour déverser parfois
notre eau n d'autres machins selon nos
humeurs et les gens en face n'ont pas la
même pour répondait pas ils ont un petit
tweet éventuellement ils n'ont pas grand
chose pour répondre et c'est la seule
chose de tente ans devrait peut-être se
remettre en question et se rendre compte
que on sort un truc qui nous avaient
clip est très violent si elle derrière
des intermittents répondre ya toujours
un contrepoids bon mathieu aimerait voir
s'il va venir voir un titre toujours
souvent de dire je vais inviter à chaque
fois à chaque et et malheureusement
c'est la part voir il ne veut pas venir
puisque tf1 ne veut pas les langues
c'est aulas pas vous nikos a toujours
voulu venir et il était d'ailleurs venu
sur france 4
ça c est pour vous dire lundi celle qui
sera notre invité c'est la première fois
qu'ils viennent d'inventer pmp
christophe dechavanne sera notre invité
est bien pour la promotion non pas là
invite les femmes étaient enfin le
laisse venir donc merci à eux il vient
pour la promotion d'âge tendre et tête
de bois voulait dire quelque chose
absolument et je voulais dire que moi
j'étais d'accord avec benjamin parce que
j'avais été tout aussi choquée et
bouleversée que lui par rapport au fait
qu'ils étaient en deuil et qu'il dit
dénonçait déjà et qu'ils étaient tristes
de l'amont mais vous qui vous viennent
de rentrer dans le monde de la télé ce
que vous trouvez que c'est un monde
hypocrite mais bien sûr que oui cyril et
on le voit mais tous vos ex soi disant
amis alors je vais pas les citer arthur
j'en passe et des meilleurs des gens qui
qui s'utilise entre eux et ça on le voit
tous les jours mais à côté de ça c'est
vrai comme le disait isabelle la télé
c'est la vraie vie on époque rite avec
ses voisins on est proscrite des fois
que son boulanger les balais chanson i
paul à la pochette est très hypocrite
avec mollo juge avait demandé le bac est
pas trop de fuites ont fait j'avais fait
un coût de vie mais c'est vrai mais
c'est ça juste un reflet de la vraie vie
en fait on voit comment avoir ton avis
là dessus parce que toi aussi tu viens
du milieu du sport est ce qu'il ya un
gap entre les deux la wii est là où il
ya des hommes il ya de l'hommerie c'est
toujours pareil on ne va ça manipule on
va là où on
bon on va là où quentin cantonnés quand
on fait de la télévision on a un retour
sur l'image sur l'ego qui est parfois un
peu disproportionné et donc là c'est
vrai que sur je pense qu'au tour de
johnny il n'y avait pas que des amis
certains étaient là pour pour soi mais
pour être là après il y avait une panne
générale et la stupeur générale on
respecte et bien sûr tout ça mais on
sent qu'il y avait aussi des collabos
bien entendu l'arrivée des
professionnels de la larme ne plus dire
évidemment c'est une très belle ambition
tout le monde le souhaite moi parfois
j'ai déjà été pourri parce qu'on sort
parfois aussi à des principes
d'éducation company est un réalisateur
qui vient sur un acteur qui parle de son
film je prie pour pacy pas la parole
parce que je sais que moi je la regarde
et je n'ai pas tellement aimé et j'ai
pas envie de lui dire que la chose pour
laquelle il a bossé pendant un an j'ai
pas aimé c'est pas drôle donc je prie
passez pas la parole mais c'est parfois
jugée par gentillesse comme ça mais
après faut du corps et un peu ses propos
après que mais voilà après fois de plus
en plus jeunes petits parce que c'est
trop facile de démonter les mecs qui
servait sur un plateau des invités
ouais c'est éviter les mecs qui
l'accueille toi tu as besoin d'eux donc
chaque systématisme sommes pas des fois
tu as des dogues
je sais que tu aimes tu le méritais le
don de deux heures